TEST
TEST TEST
TEST TESTING
TESTING TEST TESTING TESTING
TEST TEST TEST TESTING TESTING
-TEST
PROGRAM IS ABOUT
THE BEGIN.
ABOUT TO BEGIN THE PROGRAM.
WOULD YOU PLEASE TAKE YOU SEATS?
THANK YOU. IF EVERYBODY WOULD
TAKE THEIR SEATS, WE'D LIKE TO
BEGIN THE SECOND PARTED OF THE
PROGRAM NOW.
YOU'LL MISS MY IMPORTANT ENTER
DUCTION IF YOU DON'T. OKAY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, AT THIS
TIME WE ARE BEGINNING OUR LIVE
STREAM OF TONIGHT'S JOHN F.
KENNEDY CENTENNIAL PROFILE IN
COURAGE AWARD CEREMONY. I'M
DELIGHTED TO WELCOME OUR
AUDIENCE OF ONLINE VIEWERS. NOW,
THERE ARE MANY, MANY PEOPLE WHO
TAKE CREDIT FOR OUR DECISION TO
GO ONLINE. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT IDEAS CAME FROM THE
PERSON WHO CONSTANTLY GIVES US
GREAT IDEAS ON HOW TO USE
TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER INITIATIVES
AT THE LIBRARY, AND THAT'S MY
FRIEND WHO CLAIMS TO HAVE A DAY
JOB, BUT I DOUBT IT, ED
SCHLOSSBERG RIGHT THERE. THANK
END. THANK ED. [APPLAUSE] AND
YOU'LL BE HAPPY TO KNOW, ED,
THAT MIKE BARNICLE SECONDED THE
IDEA, SO WE THANK HIM FOR THAT.
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO CELEBRATE
TONIGHT, INCLUDING PRESIDENT AND
MRS. KENNEDY'S DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR THE ARTS. OUR
NEXT GUEST IS A MULTIPLE GRAMMY
AWARD WINNER, WHOSE SONGS ARE
AMONG THE GREAT PILLARS OF
AMERICAN MUSIC. HIS MUSIC SPANS
GENERATIONS, AND HIS SONGS HAVE
PROVIDED THE SOUNDTRACK ACROSS
DECADES OF OUR LIVES, PROVIDING
A SOURCE OF WARMTH AND WISDOM
AND BEAUTY IN A CHANGING WORLD.
JAMES TAYLOR'S MUSIC EMBODIES
THE ART OF SONGWRITING IN ITS
MOST PERSONAL AND UNIVERSAL
FORM. IN A CAREER THAT SPANS
ALMOST HALF A CENTURY, HE HAS
SOLD OVER 100 MILLION ALBUMS AND
HAS RECEIVED COUNTLESS HONORS,
INCLUDING THE NATIONAL MEDAL OF
THE ARTS AND THE PRESIDENTIAL
MEDAL OF FREEDOM FROM PRESIDENT
BARACK OBAMA. AND THROUGH IT
ALL... [APPLAUSE] AND THROUGH IT
ALL HE HAS MAINTAINED THE
HUMILITY AND HUMANITY, OFFERING
A PRIVATE CONCERT FOR THE VICTIM
FAMILIES OF NEWTOWN,
CONNECTICUT, A MEMORIAL SERVICE
FOR M.I.T. OFFICER SEAN COLLIER,
AND AN APPEARANCE AT THE ONE
FUND BENEFIT CONCERT IN BOSTON.
AND SO JAMES TAYLOR EXEMPLIFYIES
NOT ONLY PRESIDENT KENNEDY'S
ADMIRATION FOR THE ARTS, BUT
ALSO HIS BELIEF IN SERVICE AND
IN OUR COMMON HUMANITY. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING JAMES
TAYLOR, KIM TAYLOR, AND OWEN
YOUNG.
[APPLAUSE]
MUCH.
AND MAY I SAY HOW GREAT IT IS
TO BE HERE TONIGHT. MR. FEINBERG
INTRODUCED MY WIFE KIM, AND SHE
WILL BE OUT SHORTLY IN A
SECOND.
SHE WILL BE OUT SHORTLY, BUT
WE'RE STARTING WITHOUT HER. THIS
IS OWEN YOUNG, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, FROM THE BOSTON
SYMPHONY. [APPLAUSE]
HIMSELF A PILLAR OF THAT
INSTITUTION. AND MAY I SAY WHAT
A DELIGHT IT IS AND AN HONOR AND
FRANKLY A GREAT RELIEF TO BE IN
THE PRESENCE OF THE OBAMAS
AGAIN. [LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
IN MY MIND THERE IS A
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF J.F.K. AND
THAT OF BARACK OBAMA, AND I
THINK IT BASICALLY IS THAT BOTH
OF THESE GREAT MEN SUMMONED IN
US AND
BROUGHT OUT IN THE NATION THE
VERY BEST OF US, THE VERY BEST
OF OUR SPIRIT, OF OUR
GENEROSITY, OF OUR COURAGE AND
OF OUR PROGRESSIVE SPIRIT. MAN,
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE TONIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH AN OLD
SCOT TUNE THAT I LEARNED IN THE
MOUNTAINS OF NORTH CAROLINA.
♪♪
I CAN'T CROSS OVER ♪ AND
NEITHER HAVE I WENT TOO
FAR ♪ THERE WILL BE THOSE THAT
CAN CARRY
TWO ♪ AND BOATS SHALL ROLL MY
LOVE AND I
♪
♪♪ THERE IS A SHIP AND SHE
SAILS THE SEA ♪ SHE'S LOADED
DEEP AS DEEP CAN BE ♪ BUT NOT SO
DEEP AS THE LOVE I'M IN ♪ I
KNOW NOT HOW I SINK OR SWIM
♪ OH LOVE IT IS HANDSOME AND
LOVE IS KIND ♪ THE
SWEETEST FLOWER
WHEN FIRST ITSELF NEW ♪ BUT
LOVE GROWS OLD AND IT WAXES
COLD ♪ AND IT FADES AWAY LIKE
SUMMER DEW
♪ BUILD ME A BOAT THAT CAN
CARRY
TWO ♪ AND BOTH SHALL ROW MY
LOVE AND I
♪ AND BOTH SHALL ROW MY LOVE
AND I
♪♪ [APPLAUSE]
LULLABY WRITTEN FOR MY NEPHEW,
WHO WAS NAMED AFTER ME AND WHO
WAS BORN WHILE I WAS OVERSEAS IN
ENGLAND. SO I WAS... WHEN I
CAME BACK, MY BROTHER ALEX HAD
HAD A KID, WHICH SURPRISED US.
[LAUGHTER] WE WERE DELIGHTED BUT
ALSO SORT OF EQUALLY APPALLED.
WE COULDN'T UNDERSTAND IT,
COULDN'T GET OUR MINDS AROUND
IT. BUT I CALLED MY BROTHER THE
CONGRATULATE HIM AND ASK HIM
EXACTLY WHAT HE HAD IN MIND, AND
HE TOLD ME THAT THEY WERE
NAMING THE LITTLE A
VERMIN AFTER ME, LITTLE BABY
JAMES. SO IMMEDIATELY AFTER
ARRIVING BACK ON THESE SHORES, I
DOVE DOWN TO NORTH CAROLINA TO
SET EYES ON THE FELLA AND WROTE
THIS TUNE ON THE WAY DOWN.
♪ THERE IS A YOUNG COWBOY
SITTING ON THE RANGE
♪
HE SITS IN THE SADDLE AND HE
SLEEPS IN THE CANYON ♪ JUST
WAITING FOR SUMMER THE PASTURES
TO CHANGE
♪ HE SITS BY THE
FIRE. ♪ THINKING ABOUT WOMEN
AND GLASSES OF BEER ♪ AND
CLOSING HIS EYES AS THE DOGGIES
RETIRE ♪ HE SINGS OUT A SONG
WHICH IS SOFT BUT IT'S CLEAR ♪
JUST AS IF MAYBE SOMEONE COULD
HEAR
♪ HE SAYS GOOD NIGHT ALL YOU
MOONLIGHT LADIES ♪ ROCK-A-BYE MY
SWEET BABY JAMES DEEP GREENS
AND BLUES ARE THE COLORS I
CHOOSE ♪ WON'T YOU LET ME GO
DOWN IN MY DREAMS ♪ AS I ROCKA
BYE MY SWEET BABY JAMES ♪ NOW
THE FIRST OF DECEMBER WAS
COVERED WITH SNOW
♪ SO WAS THE TURNPIKE FROM
STOCK BRIDGE TO BOSTON ♪ THE
BERKSHIRES SEEMED DREAM-LIKE ON
ACCOUNT OF THAT FROSTING ♪ WITH
TEN MILES BEHIND ME AND 10,000
MORE TO GO ♪ THERE'S A SONG THAT
THEY SING WHEN THEY TAKE TO THE
HIGHWAY ♪ THERE'S A SONG THAT
SEA ♪ A SONG THAT THEY SING OF
THEIR HOME IN THE SKY ♪ MAYBE
YOU CAN BELIEVE IT IF IT HELPS
YOU TO SLEEP ♪ BUT SINGING SEEMS
TO WORK FINE FOR
ME ♪ SO GOOD NIGHT YOU
MOONLIGHT LADIES ♪
ROCKABYE SWEET BABY JAMES ♪
DEEP GREENS AND BLUES ARE THE
COLORS I CHOOSE ♪ WON'T YOU LET
ME GO DOWN IN MY DREAMS
♪ OH AND ROCKABYE SWEET BABY
JAMES ♪♪ [APPLAUSE]
SWEET BABY JAMES, HE'S A BIG
OLD THING TODAY. ABOUT TO TURN
50. UNBELIEVABLE. [LAUGHTER]
♪♪ ♪♪
♪ JUST YESTERDAY THEY DIDN'T
KNOW YOU WERE
BORN
♪ SUZANNE THE PLANS THEY MADE
PUT AN END TO YOU ♪ I WALKED OUT
THIS MORNING AND I WROTE DOWN
THIS SONG ♪ I JUST CAN'T
REMEMBER WHO TO SEND IT TO ♪
I'VE SEEN FIRE AND I'VE SEEN
RAIN ♪ I'VE SEEN SUNNY DAYS THAT
I THOUGHT WOULD NEVER END ♪
I'VE SEEN LONELY TIMES WHEN I
COULD NOT FIND A FRIEND ♪ BUT I
ALWAYS THOUGHT I'D SEE YOU AGAIN
♪ WON'T YOU LOOK DOWN ON ME,
JESUS ♪ YOU'VE GOT TO HELP ME
MAKE A STAND ♪ YOU'VE JUST GOT
TO SEE ME THROUGH ANOTHER DAY ♪
MY BOD'S ACHING AND MY TIME IS
AT HAND ♪ AND I WON'T MAKE IT
ANY OTHER WAY ♪ OH, I HAVE
SEEN FIRE AND I'VE SEEN RAIN ♪
I'VE SEEN SUNNY DAYS AND I
THOUGHT THEY'D NEVER END ♪ I'VE
SEEN LONELY TIMES WHEN I COULD
NOT FIND A FRIEND ♪ BUT I ALWAYS
THOUGHT I'D SEE YOU AGAIN
♪ BEEN WALKING MY MIND TO AN
EASY TIME ♪ MY BACK TURNED
TOWARD THE SUN ♪ LORD KNOWS THE
COLD WIND BLOWS IT WILL TURN
YOUR HEAD AROUND ♪ WELL, THERE'S
HOURS OF TIME ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE TALKING ABOUT THINGS TO
COME ♪ SWEET DREAMS AND FLYING
MACHINES IN PIECES ON THE GROUND
♪ OH, I'VE SEEN FIRE AND I'VE
SEEN RAIN ♪ I' SEEN SUNNY DAYS
THAT I THOUGHT WOULD NEVER END ♪
I'VE SEEN LONELY TIMES WHEN I
COULD NOT FIND A FRIEND ♪ BUT I
ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT I'D SEE YOU
SOMEHOW ONE MORE TIME AGAIN
♪ THOUGHT I'D SEE YOU ONE MORE
TIME AGAIN
♪ THERE'S A FEW THINGS COMING
MY WAY THIS TIME AROUND ♪
THOUGHT I'D SEE YOU THOUGHT I'D
SEE YOU, FIRE AND RAIN ♪ THOUGHT
I'D SEE YOU JUST ONE MORE TIME
AGAIN
♪♪
[APPLAUSE]
WIFE, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. THIS
IS KIM TAYLOR.
WE'RE GOING THE PLAY ANOTHER
SORT OF LULL ABY. I DON'T MEAN
TO PUT YOU THE SLEEP. [LAUGHTER]
THAT'S WHY WE INSISTED ON GOING
FIRST.
♪ OH THE SUN IS SURELY SINKING
NOW ♪ BUT THE MOON IS SLOWLY
RISING
♪ SO THIS OLD WORLD MUST STILL
BE SPINNING ROUND AND I STILL
LOVE YOU ♪ SO CLOSE YOUR EYES
YOU CAN CLOSE YOUR EYES IT'S ALL
RIGHT ♪ I DON'T KNOW NO LOVE
SONGS AND I CAN'T SING THE BLUES
ANYMORE ♪ BUT I CAN SING THIS
SONG AND YOU CAN SING THIS
SONG WHEN I'M GONE
♪ IT WON'T BE LONG BEFORE
ANOTHER DAY ♪ WE GHANA HAVE A
GOOD
TIME AND NO ONE'S GHANA TAKE
THAT TIME AWAY ♪ YOU CAN STAY AS
LONG AS YOU LIKE
♪ ONLY CLOSE YOUR EYES YOU CAN
CLOSE YOUR EYES IT'S ALL
RIGHT ♪ I DON'T KNOW NO LOVE
SONGS AND I CAN'T SING THE
BLUES ANYMORE ♪ BUT I CAN SING
THIS SONG AND YOU CAN SING THIS
SONG WHEN I'M
GONE
♪♪ [APPLAUSE]
GOING TO BE IT, BUT WE GOT THE
NEWS EARLIER ABOUT THE FRENCH
ELECTIONS. [CHEERING AND
APPLAUSE]
EMMANUEL MARCON HAS WON. SO
WE'RE GOING TO IN AN ATTEMPT AT
CELEBRATION AND TO HONOR THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE FRENCH
NATION AND OURSELVES, IF I MAY
PRESUME, WE'RE GOING TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT.
♪♪ ♪♪
[SINGING IN FRENCH]
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BEFORE HAVE WE TRIED TO END
THIRST AND HUNGER, POVERTY AND
DISEASE AND MASSIVE HUMAN
MISERY. WE HAVE THE POWER TO
MAKE THIS THE BEST GENERATION OF
MANKIND IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD.
WELCOME AMBASSADOR CAROLINE
KENNEDY, HONORARY PRESIDENT OF
THE JOHN F. KENNEDY LIBRARY
FOUNDATION. [APPLAUSE]
GOOD EVENING. IT'S GREAT TO BE
BACK AT THE LIBRARY. IT'S GREAT
TO BE BACK IN BOSTON. AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR TAKING SUCH GOOD
CARE OF THIS PLACE WHILE ILWAS
GONE. I WANT TO THANK MY FAMILY,
ESPECIALLY ED, FOR HIS DEVOTION
TO THIS INSTITUTION, HIS
CREATIVE VISION, HIS COMMITMENT
TO THE HISTORY AND TO OUR FAMILY
LEGACY HAS MADE THIS LIBRARY
THE JEWEL OF THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARY
SYSTEM. [APPLAUSE]
I WANT THE THANK KEN FEINBERG
FOR HIS AMAZING LEADERSHIP AND
GENEROSITY. WE SHOULD CHEER FOR
YOU. [APPLAUSE] AND I WANT THE
THANK THE FOUNDATION AND LIBRARY
STAFF FOR WORKING TO PRESERVE
THE PAST AND INSPIRE FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF PUBLIC SERVANTS
IN PRESIDENT KENNEDY'S NAME.
TONIGHT WE'RE CELEBRATING THE
TIMELESS VALUES THAT PRESIDENT
KENNEDY LIVED BY AND THAT HAVE
MADE AMERICA THE INDISPENSABLE
NATION -- COURAGE, PATRIOTISM,
JUSTICE, INNOVATION, SERVICE,
AND THE COMMITMENT TO BUILDING A
MORE PEACEFUL WORLD. AS HIS
FAMILY, WE'RE PROUD OF WHAT HE
STOOD FOR AND ITS CONTINUING
POWER. TONIGHT WE'RE HONORED BY
THE PRESENCE OF SO MANY PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO LIVE THESE VALUES
EVERY DAY. THIS AWARD CELEBRATES
THE INDISPENSABLE QUALITY OF
PUBLIC LIFE MY FATHER MOST
ADMIRED -- THE COURAGE TO RISK
YOUR CAREER TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT.
THAT MAY MEAN STANDING FOR THE
NATIONAL INTEREST WHEN OTHERS
ARE WILLING TO TRADE IT AWAY FOR
PERSONAL OR LOCAL BENEFIT. IT
MAY MEAN REACHING OUT TO WORK
WITH OTHERS TO BENEFIT THE
COMMON GOOD WHEN YOU COULD SCORE
POINTS BY CRITICIZING THEM
INSTEAD. OVER THE YEARS WE'VE
HONORED ELECTED OFFICIALS AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE. THEY HAVE
REAFFIRMED OUR FAITH IN
PRINCIPLED PUBLIC SERVICE AND
SET A STANDARD BY WHICH FUTURE
LEADERS CAN BE MEASURED. OUR
WINNERS HAVE SHOWN US THAT WE
NEED TO REWARD COURAGE IN OUR
LEADERS AND REQUIRE IT IN
OURSELVES. TODAY WHEN MANY DOUBT
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS, THIS IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER. IN ADDITION
TO OUR HONOREE, THERE ARE TWO
AMERICAN HEROES HERE TONIGHT
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SALUTE.
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN, A
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE TO MY UNCLE
TEDDY. [CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
A CHAMPION FOR JUSTICE, WORKING
FAMILIES, WOMEN AND AN
INSPIRATION TO ALL THOSE
SUFFERING FROM LOSS. THANK YOU
FOR VISITING JAPAN AND FOR
TELLING THE JAPANESE THAT I WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR YOUR SUCCESS.
[LAUGHTER] SO THEY TOO SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING I SAID.
SECRETARY JOHN KERRY, OUR
PLANET HAS NO GREATER ADVOCATE.
OUR CHILDREN NO MORE FAR-SIGHTED
WARRIOR FOR PEACE AND
DIPLOMACY. YOU'VE PURSUED A
STRATEGY OF PEACE THAT PRESIDENT
KENNEDY LAID OUT, AND WE ARE
ALL SAFER, HEALTHIER AND MORE
PROWS BECAUSE OF YOUR
INDEFATIGABLE COMMITMENT AND
OPTIMISM.
[APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU FOR TRUSTING ME
ENOUGH TO VISIT JAPAN ONLY ONCE
WHEN YOU HAD TO CHECK ON PARIS
38 TIMES. [LAUGHTER]
THIS IS A NIGHT TO CELEBRATE
POLITICS AND FAMILY. AS MY
FATHER AND UNCLES THOUGHT US,
POLITICS IS A FAMILY ENDEAVOR,
SO I WOULD LIKE IF WE COULD
OFFER A ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
FIRST LADY MICHELLE OBAMA, AND
FOR ALL THE POLITICAL SPOUSES
HERE TONIGHT. [CHEERING AND
APPLAUSE]
MANY OF YOU HERE IN THIS ROOM
CAST YOUR FIRST VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT KENNEDY. YOU TOLD ME
HOW HE CHANGED YOUR LIVES AND
TOGETHER YOU CHANGED THIS
COUNTRY. TONIGHT WE PRESENT THE
PROFILE IN COURAGE AWARD TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA, WHO HAD THE
SAME IMPACT ON ANOTHER
GENERATION, INSPIRING US, OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN, TO
CHANGE THE WORLD. ON A PERSONAL
NOTE, I WANT THE THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE CHANCE TO SERVE.
IN JAPAN I SAW FIRSTHAND WHAT
AMERICAN LEADERSHIP MEANS TO THE
WORLD. I SAW THE POWER OF OUR
COMMITMENT TO INTERNATIONAL
ORDER AND LIFTING PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY. I SAW THE HOPE AND
IDEALISM OF YOUNG PEOPLE
INSPIRED BY AMERICAN INNOVATION
AND POSSIBILITY. MOST
PROFOUNDLY, I SAW THE EMOTIONAL
OUTPOURING AFTER PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S VISIT TO HIROSHIMA
SHOWED PEOPLE AND NATIONS THAT
THEY COULD OVERCOME THE WOUNDS
OF THE PAST TO BUILD A MORE
PEACEFUL WORLD. AS I STOOD IN
THE PEACE PARK IN FRONT OF ITS
ETERNAL FLAME, I COULDN'T HELP
BUT THINK OF MY FATHER'S OWN
WORK ON THE NUCLEAR TEST BAN
TREATY AND HOW HONORED I WAS TO
KNOW THESE TWO GREAT MEN. PEOPLE
SAY IT'S HARD TO COME HOME
AFTER BEING AN AMBASSADOR. IT'S
LIKE MOVING BACK FROM COLLEGE
INTO YOUR OLD ROOM. I HAVE
CHANGED. I HAVE MADE NEW
FRIENDS. I HAVE GROWN UP. BUT
EVERYONE TREATS ME JUST THE
SAME. IN MY CASE, IT MEANS THAT
I GET TO RESUME ONE OF MY MOST
DEMANDING RESPONSIBILITIES,
WHICH IS INTRODUCING OTHER
MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY. [LAUGHTER]
IT USED TO BE TEDDY HERE AT
THIS DINNER. NOW IT'S SOMEONE
WHO ADORED HIM AND WHO I ADORE,
SOMEONE WHO HAS PITCHED IN TO
HELP ME HERE AND IN JAPAN, THE
YOUNGEST, BUT NOT THE QUIETEST
MEMBER OF THE PROFILE IN COURAGE
COMMITTEE, JACK SCHLOSSBERG.
THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU, MOTHER, FOR THAT
KIND INTRODUCTION, AND ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BRINGING ME
INTO THIS WORLD. [LAUGHTER]
YOU'RE AN AMAZING MOTHER AND
FRIEND AND ROLE MODEL FOR ME. I
KNOW EVERYONE HERE IS GRATEFUL
TO YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE, FOR
YOUR EXAMPLE. THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE TONIGHT. THIS LIBRARY
IS A VERY SPECIAL PLACE FOR ME
AND MY SISTERS IN THE SAME WAY
THAT IT IS SPECIAL FOR ANYONE
WHO VISIT IT. IT ALLOWS US TO
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH MAN WE
NEVER KNEW BUT WHO HOLDS SUCH A
SPECIAL PLACE IN OUR HEARTS. WE
CAN COME HERE TO HEAR HIS VOICE,
READ HIS WORDS, LOOK THROUGH
HIS OLD NOTEBOOKS AND TIES AND
FIND STRENGTH AND GUIDANCE AND
LAUGHTER FROM THE SPIRIT THAT
LIVES ON HERE. COURAGE WAS A
QUALITY THAT MY GRANDFATHER MOST
ADMIRED. AS A YOUNG MAN, A
SOLDIER AND A PRESIDENT, HE
DISPLAYED IT THROUGHOUT HIS OWN
LIFE AND ENCOURAGED OTHER
LEADERS TO DO THE SAME. AS WE
MARK 100 YEARS SINCE PRESIDENT
KENNEDY WAS BORN, WE CELEBRATE
HIS LIFE AND ALL THAT HE
ACHIEVED IN IT, AND WE REMEMBER
THAT HE HIMSELF REPRESENTS WHAT
IS POSSIBLE IN AMERICA AND ALL
THE WORK LEFT UNDONE. THROUGHOUT
HIS PRESIDENCY, MY GRANDFATHER
MADE IT CLEAR THAT HE ALONE
COULD FIX NOTHING, THAT HE ALONE
HAD NO ANSWERS. HE HAD THE
COURAGE TO REPUBLICANLY ADMIT
AMERICA'S OWN SHORTCOMINGS, TO
THEN LAY OUT BOLD PLANS THE
ADDRESS THOSE PROBLEMS, AND TO
ASK HIS FELLOW AMERICANS FOR
HELP IN SOLVING THEM. AND IN
DOING, SO HE INSPIRED A
GENERATION TO PUBLIC SERVICE AND
TO ASK WHAT THEY COULD DO FOR
THEIR COUNTRY. PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA INSPIRED ME THE SAME WAY.
MY LIFE CHANGED IN 2008 BECAUSE
A YOUNG CANDIDATE WAS FIRED UP
AND READY TO GO AND SAID, YES,
WE CAN. WITHOUT BARACK OBAMA, I
MIGHT STILL BE SITTING ON MY
COACH EATING DORITOS AND
WATCHING SPORTS. [LAUGHTER]
PRESIDENT OBAMA EMBODIES THE
DEFINITION OF COURAGE OFFERED BY
ERNEST HEMINGWAY AND A FAVORITE
OF PRESIDENT KENNEDY'S "GRACE
UNDER PRESSURE." FROM HIS FIRST
DAYS IN OFFICE UNTIL THE LAST,
THE PRESIDENT CONSISTENTLY PUT
THE NATIONAL INTEREST ABOVE HIS
OWN POLITICAL INTEREST WHILE
RESISTING THE POLITICS OF
CYNICISM IN A SYSTEM THAT ALL
TOO OFTEN ENCOURAGES IT. HE HAD
THE COURAGE TO PURSUE
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE REFORM
AS HIS FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS,
KNOWING THE ISSUE WOULD COST HIM
AND THE PARTY POLITICALLY. HE
CONTINUED A FIGHT THAT WAS WAGED
DURING THE KENNEDY
ADMINISTRATION, THAT MY UNCLE
TEDDY FOUGHT FOR FOR 50 YEARS IN
THE SENATE AND DID WHAT NO
PRESIDENT HAD BEEN ABLE TO DO IN
70 YEARS IN PASSING THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. [CHEERING
AND APPLAUSE]
WE SAW THIS WEEK THAT IT'S A
LOT EASIER TO CRITICIZE AND
DISMANTLE. PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD
THE COURAGE TO GOVERN
RESPONSIBLY. HE HAD THE COURAGE
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AGGRESSIVELY,
FIGHTING FOR RESPONSIBLE ENERGY
POLICIES AND CHALLENGING
CONGRESS TO SUPPORT THE CLEAN
POWER PLAN, AND HE BROUGHT THE
WORLD TOGETHER IN PARIS TO SET A
LIMIT ON GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
JUST AS PRESIDENT KENNEDY DID
WITH THE SPACE PROGRAM,
PRESIDENT OBAMA GAVE SCIENTIFIC
TECHNOLOGY THE HIGHEST NATIONAL
PRIORITY UNDER HIS CLIMATE PLAN
ON AN ISSUE THAT WILL SHAPE LIFE
ON EARTH FOR MY GENERATIONS AND
GENERATIONS TO COME, THE
PRESIDENT WAS BOLD AN UNAFRAID.
HE PURSUED NUCLEAR DISARMAMENT
THROUGHOUT HIS PRESIDENCY AND
HAD THE COURAGE TO CONFRONT
AMERICA'S OWN HISTORY WHEN
FITSING HIROSHIMA. HE REPEATEDLY
CALLED FOR SENSIBLE ACTION ON
GUN CONTROL TRAGEDY AFTER
TRAGEDY. [APPLAUSE] HE SHOWED ME
AND MY GENERATION WHAT IS
POSSIBLE FROM POLITICS AND GAVE
US A NEW STANDARD OF POLITICAL
COURAGE TO GUIDE US GOING
FORWARD. HE CONNECTED US TO ONE
ANOTHER WITH HIS HOPES AND HIS
DETERMINATION. WE ALL,
ESPECIALLY YOUNG AMERICANS, OWE
A GREAT DEBT TO THIS COURAGEOUS
PRESIDENT. WE CAN LIVE IN THE
JUST, INCLUSIVE, COMPASSIONATE
AND STRONG NATION THAT PRESIDENT
KENNEDY IMAGINED AND FOUGHT FOR
IF WE CHOOSE THE TYPE OF
LEADERSHIP THAT DEFINED
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S LAST EIGHT
YEARS IN OFFICE. THAT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS CITIZENS AND
IS AS IMPORTANT TODAY AS IT EVER
HAS BEEN. TONIGHT THE KENNEDY
LIBRARY AND MY FAMILY ARE PROUD
TO HONOR THIS COURAGEOUS
PRESIDENT, AND NOW I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK THE PRESIDENT, MRS.
OBAMA, MY PARENTS AND SISTERS TO
COME ON STAGE TO PRESENT THE
2017 PROFILE IN COURAGE AWARD TO
BARACK OBAMA. THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
>> HI THERE, EVERYBODY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. PLEASE,
EVERYBODY, HAVE A SEAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FIRST
OF ALL, THANK YOU SO MUCH, JACK,
FOR THAT REALLY KIND
INTRODUCTION. AND I LIKE THE
SOCKS.
I ALSO WANT THE THANK YOU AND
ROSE AND TATIANA AND YOUR DAD
FOR SHARING CAROLINE WITH US
THESE PAST FEW YEARS AS
AMERICA'S AMBASSADOR TO JAPAN.
CAROLINE, TRUE TO FORM, YOU DID
YOUR COUNTRY PROUD, AND I'M SURE
YOUR FATHER AND MOM WOULD HAVE
BEEN PROUDEST OF ALL. I SURE WAS
PROUD. AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR FRIENDSHIP. I WANT THE
THANK KEN FEINBERG FOR HIS
SERVICE AS CHAIRMAN OF THE JOHN
F. KENNEDY LIBRARY FOUNDATION.
THESE PAST 12 YEARS HE ALSO
RENDERED OUTSTANDING SERVICE TO
MY ADMINISTRATION WHEN WE WERE
DEALING WITH THE B.P. OIL SPILL,
9/11. HE HAS RENDERED PUBLIC
SERVICE AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN. WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
HIM. IT IS WONDERFUL...
[APPLAUSE]
IT IS WONDERFUL TO SEE SENATORS
MARKEY AND SENATOR WARREN, MY
DEAR FRIEND AND FORMER GOVERNOR
DEVAL PATRICK AND HIS LOVELY
WIFE DIANE, GOVERNORS AND
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, CARDINAL
O'MALLEY, ONE OF THE FINEST
SECRETARIES OF STATE EVER TO
REPRESENT AMERICA AROUND THE
WORLD, JOHN KERRY. [APPLAUSE]
AND THERESA. AND THE BEST VICE
PRESIDENT THIS COUNTRY HAS EVER
KNOWN, MR. JOE BIDEN. [CHEERING
AND APPLAUSE]
I ALSO WANT TO THANK MICHELLE
OBAMA FOR AFTER THE PRESIDENCY
STICKING WITH ME. [LAUGHTER]
BECAUSE I THINK SHE FELT AN
OBLIGATION TO THE COUNTRY TO
STAY ON, BUT ONCE HER OFFICIAL
DUTIES WERE OVER, IT WASN'T
CLEAR.
I LOVE MY WIFE. AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR HER. AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS AMERICA'S
VERY GOOD FORTUNE TO HAVE HER AS
FIRST LADY. [CHEERING AND
APPLAUSE]
SO I'M HUMBLED BY THIS EVENING
AND TO BE HONORED GAMELY THAT
HAS GIVEN THIS COUNTRY SO MUCH,
A FAMILY THAT'S CHALLENGED US TO
ASK WHAT WE CAN DO FOR OUR
COUNTRY, TO DREAM AND SAY WHY
NOT, TO SEEK A CAUSE THAT
ENDURES, TO SAIL AGAINST THE
WIND IN ITS PURSUIT. THAT'S WHAT
THIS FAMILY HAS DONE FOR
AMERICA. AND TO ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE KENNEDY FAMILY THAT ARE
HERE TONIGHT, THANK YOU. I COULD
NOT BE MORE GRATEFUL TO THE
PROFILE IN COURAGE AWARD
COMMITTEE FOR THIS HONOR. I'M
ALSO GRATEFUL THAT UNLIKE THE
NOBEL PRIZE COMMITTEE, YOU
WAITED UNTIL I WAS OUT OF
OFFICE.
[LAUGHTER]
HOW FITTING THAT WE GATHER HERE
THIS MONTH, THE 100th
ANNIVERSARY OF PRESIDENT
KENNEDY'S BIRTH. I WAS BORN THE
YEAR HE TOOK OFFICE, WHICH MAKES
ME 55 YEARS OLD. HAD HE LIVED
TO FINISH TWO TERMS, HE WOULD
HAVE BEEN JUST 51, AND
REREMARKED ON THAT POSSIBILITY
ONCE. "IT HAS BEEN SUGGESTED,"
HE SAID, "THAT WHETHER I SERVE
ONE OR TWO TERMS IN THE
PRESIDENCY, I WILL FIND MYSELF
AT THE END OF THAT PERIOD AT
WHAT MIGHT BE CALLED THE AWKWARD
AGE -- TOO OLD TO BEGIN A
CAREER AND TOO YOUNG TO WRITE MY
MEMOIRS." NOW, I HADN'T SEEN
THIS QUOTE WHEN I WROTE MY FIRST
MEMOIR AT 33. [LAUGHTER] I'M
NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF MY SECOND.
MOREOVER, I EXPECT TO BE BUSY IF
NOT WITH A SECOND CAREER THAN
AT LEAST A SECOND ACT. BUT IT IS
TRUE THAT I'M AT THE AGE, AT
THAT TURN IN THE ROAD WHERE ONE
LOOKS BACK AS WELL AS FORWARD TO
REMEMBER WHERE ONE HAS BEEN SO
AS BETTER TO CHART WHERE ONE IS
GOING. AND ONE THING I'M CERTAIN
IS THAT I WAS LUCKY TO BE BORN
INTO THAT NEW FRONTIER, A NEW
WORLD, AND A NEW GENERATION OF
AMERICANS.
MY LIFE IN MANY WAYS WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE
VISION THAT J.F.K. ETCHED INTO
THE CHARACTER AND HEART OF
AMERICA.
FOR THOSE OF US OF A CERTAIN
AGE, THE KENNEDYS SYMBOLIZE A
SET OF VALUES AND ATTITUDES
ABOUT CIVIC LIFE THAT MADE IT
SUCH AN ATTRACTIVE CALLING, THE
IDEA THAT POLITICS, IN FACT,
COULD BE A NOBLE AND WORTHWHILE
PURSUIT, THE NOTION THAT OUR
PROBLEMS WHILE SIGNIFICANT ARE
NEVER INSURMOUNTABLE, THE BELIEF
THAT AMERICA'S PROMISE MIGHT
EMBRACE THOSE WHO HAD ONCE BEEN
LOCKED OUT OR LEFT BEHIND, AND
THAT OPPORTUNITY AND DIGNITY
WOULD NO LONGER BE RESTRICTED TO
THE FEW BUT EXTENDED TO THE
MANY, THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT
EACH OF US HAS THE PLAY A PART
IN OUR NATION'S DESTINY, AND BY
VIRTUE OF BEING AMERICAN, PLAY A
PART IN THE DESTINY OF THE
WORLD. I CAN SAY TRUTHFULLY THAT
THE EXAMPLE OF JACK AND BOBBY
KENNEDY HELPED GUIDE ME IN THE
POLITICS AND THE GUIDANCE OF
TEDDY KENNEDY MADE ME A BETTER
PUBLIC SERVANT ONCE I ARRIVED IN
WASHINGTON. I HAVE TO IMAGINE
IT WOULD GIVE THEM GREAT PRIDE
TO SEE A NEW GENERATION OF
KENNEDYS LIKE JOE CARVING THEIR
OWN PROUD PATH IN PUBLIC
SERVICE. [APPLAUSE]
FOR WHATEVER REASON I RECEIVE
THIS AWARD, FOR WHATEVER THE
SCALE, THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
OVERCAME AND THE SCOPE OF
PROGRESS WE MADE OVER MY
PRESIDENCY, IT IS WORTH POINTING
OUT THAT IN MANY WAYS THE TIME
THAT PRESIDENT KENNEDY
CONFRONTED WERE FAR MORE
PERILOUS THAN THE ONES THAT WE
CONFRONT TODAY. HE ENTERED THE
OVAL OFFICE AT JUST 43, ONLY A
FEW YEARS AFTER KHRUSHCHEV HAD
THREATENED TO BURY AMERICA. WARS
WAGED AROUND THE WORLD. LARGE
SWATHS OF THE COUNTRY KNEW
POVERTY FAR DEEPER AND MORE
WIDESPREAD THAN WE SEE TODAY. A
YOUNG PREACHER'S CAUSE WAS JUST
GAINING TRACTION ACROSS A LAND
SEGREGATED BY CUSTOM BUT BY LAW,
AND YET WHEN THAT VOLATILE
TINDERBOX OF A TIME, PRESIDENT
KENNEDY LED WITH A STEADY HAND,
DIFFUSING THE MOST PERILOUS
MOMENTS OF THE COLD WAR WITHOUT
FIRING A SINGLE SHOT, ENFORCING
THE RIGHTS OF YOUNG BLACK MEN
AND WOMEN TO STUDY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF THEIR CHOICE,
UNLEASHING A CORE OF YOUNG
VOLUNTEERS AS AMBASSADORS FOR
PEACE IN DISTANT CORNERS OF THE
GLOBE, SETTING AMERICA'S SIGHTS
ON THE MOON PRECISELY BECAUSE IT
WAS HARD, AND WILLING TO
CONSIDER THE POSSIBILITY THAT WE
MIGHT NOT WIN THIS SPACE RACE
BECAUSE HE HAD AN UNWAVERING
FAITH IN THE CHARACTER OF THE
PEOPLE THAT HE LED -- RESILIENT,
OPTIMISTIC, INNOVATIVE, AND
COURAGEOUS.
IT'S WORTH REMEMBERING THIS:
THE TIMES IN WHICH PRESIDENT
KENNEDY LED US BECAUSE FOR MANY
AMERICANS I KNOW THAT THIS FEELS
LIKE AN UNCERTAIN AND EVEN
PERILOUS TIME. THE FORCES OF
GLOBALIZATION AND TECHNOLOGY HAS
UPENDED MANY OF OUR ESTABLISHED
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE ECONOMY
AND HAS PROVIDED GREAT
OPPORTUNITY BUT ALSO GREAT
INEQUALITY AND UNCERTAINTY FOR
FAR TOO MANY. OUR POLITICS
REMAIN FILLED WITH VISION AND
DISCORD AND EVERYWHERE WE SEE
THE RISK OF FALLING INTO THE
REFUGE OF TRIBE AND CLAN AND
ANGER AT THOSE THAT DON'T LOOK
LIKE US OR HAVE THE SAME
SURNAMES OR PRAY THE WAY WE
THIS. -- WE DO. AT SUCH MOMENTS
COURAGE IS NECESSARY, AT SUCH
MOMENTS WE NEED COURAGE TO STAND
UP TO HATE, NOT JUST IN OTHERS
BUT IN OURSELVES. AT SUCH
MOMENTS WE NEED THE COURAGE TO
STAND UP TO DOGMA, NOT JUST IN
OTHERS, BUT IN OURSELVES. AT
SUCH MOMENTS WE NEED COURAGE TO
BELIEVE THAT TOGETHER WE CAN
TACKLE BIG CHALLENGES LIKE
INEQUALITY AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
AT SUCH MOMENTS IT'S NECESSARY
FOR US TO SHOW COURAGE IN
CHALLENGING THE STATUS QUO AND
IN FIGHTING THE GOOD FIGHT, BUT
ALSO SHOW THE COURAGE TO LISTEN
TO ONE ANOTHER AND SEEK COMMON
GROUND AND EMBRACE PRINCIPLED
COMPROMISE, COURAGE PRESIDENT
KENNEDY KNEW REQUIRES SOMETHING
MORE THAN JUST THE ABSENCE OF
FEAR. ANY FOOL CAN BE FEARLESS.
COURAGE, TRUE COURAGE, DERIVES
FROM THAT SENSE OF WHO WE ARE.
WHAT ARE OUR BEST SELVES? WHAT
ARE OUR MOST IMPORTANT
COMMITMENTS? AND THE BELIEF THAT
WE CAN DIG
DEEP AND DO HARD THINGS FOR THE
ENDURING BENEFIT FOR OTHERS.
THAT'S WHY J.F.K.'S FIRST
INAUGURAL STILL RINGS TRUE.
THAT'S WHY BOBBY'S CAMPAIGN
STILL MEANS SO MUCH. THAT'S WHY
THE END YEAH'S CAUSE
CAUSE -- TEDDY'S CAUSE ENDURES
AND WE STILL LOVE HIM SO MUCH.
BECAUSE OF THE TRAGEDIES THAT
BEFELL EACH OF THEM, SOMETIMES
WE FORGET HOW FUNDAMENTALLY THE
STORY THEY TOLD US ABOUT
OURSELVES CHANGED THE TRAJECTORY
OF AMERICA, AND THAT'S OFTEN
WHERE COURAGE BEGINS, WITH THE
STORY WE TELL OURSELVES ABOUT
WHO WE ARE AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT
AND ABOUT OUR OWN CAPACITY TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
WE LIVE IN A TIME OF GREAT
CYNICISM ABOUT OUR INSTITUTIONS.
THAT'S ONE OF THE FEW THINGS
THAT DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
CAN AGREE ON.
IT'S A CYNICISM THAT IS MOST
CORROSIVE WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
SYSTEM OF
SELF-GOVERNMENT,
THAT THERE IS JAGGED BUT
ULTIMATELY FORWARD PROGRESS THAT
IMPEDES OUR CHILDREN'S ABILITY
TO SEE IN THE NOISY AND OFTEN
TOO TRIVIAL PURR SUITS OF
POLITICS THE POSSIBILITY OF OUR
DEMOCRACY DOING BIG THINGS. OF
COURSE, THE SAME FOR ELECTED
OFFICIALS IS NOT NEW, AS MANY OF
YOU IN THE ROOM CAN TELL
OTHERS. SIX YEARS AGO PRESIDENT
KENNEDY QUOTED A COLUMNIST IN
PROFILES IN COURAGE WHO HAD
WRITTEN "PEOPLE DON'T GIVE A
DAMN WHAT THE AVERAGE SENATOR OR
CONGRESSMAN SAYS. THE REASON
THEY DON'T CARE IS THAT THEY
KNOW WHAT YOU HEAR IN CONGRESS
IS 99% TRITE, IGNORANCE, AND
TEMPERATURE GOINGRY AND NOT TO
BE RELIED UPON," WHICH IS
PERHAPS A LITTLE HARSH. 99%
SEEMS HIGH. [LAUGHTER]
85%. [LAUGHTER] BUT PRESIDENT
KENNEDY ALSO WROTE THAT THE
COMPLICATION OF PUBLIC BUSINESS
AND THE COMPETITION FOR THE
PUBLIC'S ATTENTION HAVE OBSCURED
INNUMERABLE ACTS OF POLITICAL
COURAGE, LARGE AND SMALL,
PERFORMED ALMOST DAILY --
INNUMERABLE ACTS OF POLITICAL
COURAGE, LARGE AND SMALL,
PERFORMED ALMOST DAILY. AND THAT
IS TRUE. I HAVE SEEN IT, I HAVE
WITNESSED IT. I'VE BEEN
THINKING ON THIS NOTION OF
COURAGE THIS WEEKEND, IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT SOME OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN ELECTED TO CONGRESS
THE SAME YEAR I WAS ELECTED TO
THE WHITE HOUSE. MANY OF THEM
WERE NEW TO WASHINGTON. THEIR
ENTIRE CAREERS AHEAD OF THEM.
AND IN THAT VERY FIRST TERM,
THEY HAD TO TAKE TOUGH VOTE
AFTER TOUGH VOTE, BECAUSE WE
WERE IN CRISIS. THEY TOOK VOTES
TO SAVE THE FINANCIAL SYSTEM AND
THE ECONOMY EVEN WHEN IT WAS
HIGHLY UNPOPULAR. THEY TOOK
VOTES TO SAVE THE AUTOINDUSTRY
WHEN EVEN IN MICHIGAN PEOPLE
DIDN'T WANT TO SEE BAILOUTS.
THEY TOOK VOTES THE CRACK DOWN
ON ABUSES ON WALL STREET DESPITE
PRESSURE FROM LOBBYISTS AND
SOMETIMES THEIR DONORS. AND THEY
FOUND THEMSELVES IN THE MIDST
OF A GREAT DEBATE. A DEBATE THAT
HAD BEEN GOING ON FOR DECADES,
A DEBATE THAT THE KENNEDY FAMILY
HAD PARTICIPATED IN AND HELPED
LEAD, A DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER A
NATION AS WEALTHY AS THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA WOULD FINALLY
MAKE HEALTHCARE NOT A PRIVILEGE
BY A RIGHT FOR ALL AMERICANS.
[APPLAUSE]
AND THERE WAS A REASON WHY
HEALTHCARE REFORM HAD NOT BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED BEFORE. IT WAS
HARD. IT INVOLVED ONE-SIXTH OF
THE ECONOMY AND ALL MANNER OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND INTERESTS. IT
WAS EASILY SUBJECT TO
MISINFORMATION AND FEAR
MONGERING. AND SO BY THE TIME
THE VOTE CAME UP TO PASS THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT, THESE
FRESHMAN CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN
KNEW THAT THEY HAD THE MAKE A
CHOICE, THAT THEY HAD A CHANCE
TO ENSURE MILLIONS AND PREVENT
UNTOLD WORRY AND SUFFERING AND
BANKRUPTCY AND EVEN DEATH, BUT
THIS SAME VOTE WOULD LIKELY COST
THEM THEIR NEW SEATS, PERHAPS
END THEIR POLITICAL CAREERS.
AND THESE MEN AND WOMEN DID THE
RIGHT THING. THEY DID THE HARD
THING.
THEIRS WAS A PROFILE IN
COURAGE, BECAUSE OF THAT VOTE,
20 MILLION PEOPLE GOT HEALTH
INSURANCE WHO DIDN'T HAVE IT
BEFORE. AND MOST OF THEM...
[APPLAUSE] MOST OF THEM DID LOSE
THEIR SEATS, BUT THEY WERE TRUE
TO WHAT PRESIDENT KENNEDY
DEFINED IN HIS BOOK AS A
CONGRESSIONAL PROFILE IN
COURAGE, THE DESIRE TO MAINTAIN
A REPUTATION FOR INTEGRITY THAT
IS STRONGER THAN A DESIRE TO
MAINTAIN OFFICE. THE DEZAIRE TO
MAINTAIN A REPUTATION FOR
INTEGRITY THAT IS STRONGER THAN
THE DESIRE TO MAINTAIN OFFICE. A
CONSCIENCE, PERSONAL STANDARD
OF ETHICS, INTEGRITY, MORALITY
THAT IS STRONGER THAN THE
PRESSURES OF PUBLIC DISAPPROVAL
OR PARTY DISAPPROVAL, A FAITH
THAT THE RIGHT COURSE WOULD
ULTIMATELY BE VINDICATEED, A
FAITH THAT OVERCAME FEAR OF
PUBLIC REPRISAL. IT WAS A
PERSONAL SACRIFICE, BUT I KNOW
BECAUSE I'VE SPOKEN TO MANY OF
THEM THAT THEY THOUGHT AND STILL
THINK IT WAS WORTH IT.
AS EVERYONE HERE NOW KNOWS,
THIS GREAT DEBATE IS NOT SETTLED
BUT CONTINUES. AND IT IS MY
FERVENT HOPE AND THE HOPE OF
MILLIONS THAT REGARDLESS OF
PARTY, SUCH COURAGE IS STILL
POSSIBLE, THAT TODAY'S MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS, REGARDLESS OF
PARTY, ARE WILLING THE LOOK AT
THE FACTS AND SPEAK THE TRUTH
EVEN WHEN IT CONTRADICTS PARTY
POSITIONS. I HOPE THAT CURRENT
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS RECALL THAT
IT ACTUALLY DOESN'T TAKE A LOT
OF COURAGE TO AID THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY POWERFUL, ALREADY
COMFORTABLE, ALREADY
INFLUENTIAL, BUT IT DOES REQUIRE
SOME COURAGE TO CHAMPION THE
VULNERABLE AND THE SICK,
AND THE INFIRM, THOSE WHO OFTEN
HAVE NO ACCESS TO THE CORRIDORS
OF POWER. I HOPE THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT COURAGE MEANS
NOT SIMPLY DOING WHAT IS
POLITICALLY EXPEDIENT BUT DOING
WHAT THEY BELIEVE DEEP IN THEIR
HEARTS IS RIGHT. AND THIS KIND
OF COURAGE IS REQUIRED FROM ALL
OF US. THOSE OF US WHO CONSIDER
OURSELVES PROGRESSIVE, THOSE OF
US WHO ARE DEMOCRATS, WE'VE GOT
SOME SOUL SEARCHING TO DO TO SEE
WHAT KIND OF COURAGE WE SHOW.
WE HAVE OUR OWN DOGMAS.
THOSE OF US NOT IN ELECTED
OFFICE HAVE THE SHOW SOME
COURAGE. WE'RE PRONE TO BESTOW
THE MANTLE OF COURAGE TOO EASILY
ON THE PROMINENT AND POWERFUL
AND TOO EAGER THE WRAP OURSELVES
IN CYNICISM WHEN THEY LET US
DOWN BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
PERFECT. WE LOSE SIGHT SOMETIMES
OF OUR OWN OBLIGATIONS, EACH OF
OURS, ALL THE QUIET ACTS OF
COURAGE THAT UNFOLD AROUND US
EVERY SINGLE DAY, ORDINARY
AMERICANS, WHO GIVE SOMETHING OF
THEMSELVES NOT FOR PERSONAL
GAIN BUT FOR THE ENDURING
BENEFIT OF ANOTHER, THE COURAGE
OF A SINGLE MOM WHO IS WORKING
TWO JOBS TO MAKE SURE HER KIDS
CAN GO TO COLLEGE, THE COURAGE
OF A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WHO IS
KEEPING FOLKS ON THE PAYROLL
BECAUSE HE KNOWS A FAMILY
RELEASE ON IT, EVEN IF IT'S NOT
ALWAYS THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
HIS BOTTOM LINE, THE COURAGE OF
SOMEBODY WHO VOLUNTEERS TO HELP
SOME KIDS WHO NEED HELP. WHEN
WE RECOGNIZE THESE ACTS OF
COURAGE, WE THEN NECESSARILY
RECOGNIZE OUR OWN RESPONSIBILITY
AS CITIZENS AND AS PART OF THE
HUMAN FAMILY TO GET INVOLVED AND
THE GET ENGAGED AND TO TAKE A
STAND, TO VOTE, TO PAY
ATTENTION. I'M REMINDED OF A
STORY TEDDY ONCE TOLD ME ABOUT
HIS EXPERIENCE MANY YEARS AGO
WHEN TEDDY, JR.,, NOW STATE
SENATOR TED KENNEDY, JR., WAS
SLEEPING AFTER ONE OF HIS CANCER
TREATMENTS. AND TED WOULD
WANDER THE HALLS OF THE HOSPITAL
AND TALK WITH OTHER PARENTS,
KEEPING VIGIL OVER THEIR OWN
CHILDREN, AND THESE PARENTS
LIVED IN CONSTANT FEAR OF WHAT
MIGHT HAPPEN IF THEY COULDN'T
AFFORD THE NEXT TREATMENT. SOME
CALCULATING IN THEIR OWN MINDS
WHAT THEY MIGHT HAVE TO SELL OR
BORROW JUST TO MAKE IT FOR A FEW
MORE MONTHS, SOME BARGAINING
WITH GOD FOR WHATEVER THEY COULD
GET, AND RIGHT THERE IN THE
QUIET OF NIGHT, WORKING PEOPLE
OF MODEST MEANS AND ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL MEN IN AMERICA
SHARED THE SAME INTIMATE AND
IMMEDIATE SENSE OF HELPLESS
NESS. AND TED COULD, OF COURSE,
AFFORD HIS SON'S TREATMENT, BUT
IT WAS THAT QUIET, DIGNIFIED
COURAGE OF OTHERS TO ENDURE THE
MOST FRIGHTENING THING
IMAGINABLE AND TO DO WHAT IT
TAKES ON BEHALF OF THEIR LOVED
ONES THAT HAD COMPELLED TEDDY TO
MAKE THOSE PARENTS HIS CAUSE,
NOT OUT OF SELF-INTEREST, BUT
OUT OF A SELFLESS CONCERN FOR
THOSE WHO SUFFER. THAT'S WHERE
THE ORDINARY COURAGE OF EVERYDAY
PEOPLE CAN INSPIRE WHEN YOU'RE
PAYING ATTENTION, THE QUIET
COURAGE OF ORDINARY PEOPLE DOING
THE RIGHT THING DAY IN AND KAY
OUT. THEY DON'T GET ATTENTION
FOR IT. THEY DON'T SEEK IT. THEY
DON'T GET AWARDS FOR IT, BUT
THAT'S WHAT DEFINED AMERICA. I
THINK OF WOMEN LIKE MY
GRANDMOTHER AND SO MANY LIKE HER
WHO WORKED THEIR WAY UP FROM A
SECRETARIAL POOL TO MANAGEMENT
AND IN THE PROCESS PUSHED THE
GLASS CEILING JUST A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER. I THINK ABOUT PEOPLE
LIKE MICHELLE'S DAD, WHO DESPITE
M.S. GOT UP EVERY SINGLE
MORNING, HAD THE WAKE UP AN HOUR
EARLY TO BUTTON HIS SHIRT UP
AND PUT ON HIS CLOTHES AND TAKE
THOSE TWO CANES HE USED AND GO
TO WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT HE WAS SUPPORTING HIS
FAMILY, NOT MISSING A DANCE
RECITAL OR A BASKETBALL GAME. I
THINK OF THE TROOPS AND THE COPS
AND THE FIRST RESPONDERS THAT
I'VE MET WHO PUT THEMSELVES AT
RISK FOR STRANGERS THEY WILL
NEVER KNOW AND BUSINESS OWNERS
WHO MAKE EVERY KIND OF SACRIFICE
THEY CAN TO MAKE SURE THEIR
WORKERS HAVE A SHOT AND WORKERS
WHO TAKE A RISK OF STARTING A
NEW CAREER, RETRAINING AT MY
AGE, KIDS IN THE PEACE CORPS
WORKING TO BUILD BRIDGES OF
UNDERSTANDING IN OTHER NATIONS
TO SPREAD THE SAME VALUES THAT
HELPED BRING DOWN AN IRON
CURTAIN, BANISH THE SCOURGE OF
APARTHEID, EXPAND THE BOUNDARIES
OF HUMAN FREEDOM. I THINK OF
DREAMERS WHO SUPPRESSED THEIR
FEARS TO KEEP WORKING AND
STRIVING IN THE ONLY COUNTRY
THEY'VE EVER CALLED HOME, AND
EVERY AMERICAN WHO STANDS UP FOR
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT THEIR PARENTS, THEIR
GRANDPARENTS, THEIR GREAT
GRANDPARENTS WERE IMMIGRANTS,
TOO, AND THEY KNOW THAT AMERICA
IS AN IDEA THAT ONLY GROWS
STRONGER WITH EACH NEW PERSON
WHO ADOPTS OUR COMMON CREED.
[APPLAUSE]
ACTIVIST WHO THINKS OF THE
INJUSTICES IN OR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM, NOT WITH
VIOLENCE, NO WITH DESPAIR, BUT
WITH PEACEFUL PROTEST ANALYSIS
AND CONSTRUCTIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR CHANGE. I THINK OF THE
POWERLESS WHO CROSSED A BRIDGE
IN SELMA AND DISCOVERED THEY HAD
POWER, THOSE WHO GATHERED TO
STONEWALL AND DISCOVERED THEY
HAD A VOICE, THOSE WHO MARCHED
ON WASHINGTON BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVED THAT THEY, WITHOUT AN
ARMY, WITHOUT GREAT WEALTH,
COULD SOMEHOW CHANGE THE VERY
FABRIC OF THE GREATEST POWER ON
EARTH AND KEPT ON UNTIL THEY
STRETCHED THE LOFTY IDEALS OF
OUR FOUNDING TO ENCIRCLE
EVERYONE. EVERY CITIZEN INSPIRED
BY THAT HISTORY WHO DIPS THEIR
TOES IN THE WATER OF ACTIVE
DEMOCRACY FOR THE FIRST TIME AND
MUSTERS UP THE DETERMINATION
THE TRY AND FAIL AND TRY AGAIN
AND SOMETIMES FAIL AGAIN AND
STILL TRY AGAIN KNOWING THEIR
EFFORTS ARE NOT ALWAYS REWARDED
RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
IN THAT UPWARD TRAJECTORY OF THE
AMERICAN STORY, THE STORY THAT
NOBODY TOLD BETTER THAN JOHN F.
KENNEDY.
THAT VERY KENNEDYESQUE IDEA
THAT AMERICA IS NOT THE PROJECT
OF ANY ONE PERSON AND THAT EACH
OF US CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
ALL OF US OUGHT TO TRY. THAT
QUIET STURDY CITIZENSHIP THAT I
SEE ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY, AND
THAT I ESPECIALLY SEE IN YOUNG
PEOPLE LIKE JACK AND ROSE AND
TATYANA, MALIA AND SASHA AND
YOUR KIDS. I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
PRESIDENT KENNEDY'S AIDE AND
FRIEND, HISTORIAN ARTHUR
SCHLESINGER, JR., WAS RIGHT WHEN
HE WROTE THAT HISTORY UNFOLDS
IN CYCLES, BUT I THIS KNOW THAT
IT DOESN'T MOVE IN A STRAIGHT
LINE. I KNOW THAT THE VALUES AND
THE PROGRESS THAT WE CHERISH
ARE NOT INEVITABLE. THEY ARE
FRAGILE AND NEED A CONSTANT
RENEWAL. I'VE SAID BEFORE THAT I
BELIEVE WHAT DR. KING SAID,
THAT THE ARC OF THE UNIVERSE IS
LONG BUT IT BENDS TOWARD
JUSTICE, BUT I'VE ALSO SAID IT
DOES NOT BEND ON ITS OWN. IT
BENDS BECAUSE WE BEND IT,
BECAUSE WE PUT OUR HANDS ON THAT
ARC AND WE MOVE IT IN THE
DIRECTION OF JUSTICE AND FREEDOM
AND EQUALITY AND KINDNESS AND
GENEROSITY. IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
ON ITS OWN. AND SO WE'RE
CONSTANTLY HAVING TO MAKE A
CHOICE, BECAUSE PROGRESS IS
FRAGILE, AND IT'S PRECISELY THAT
PRA JILL -- FRAGILITY THAT IS A
PRECONDITION OF THE QUALITY OF
CHARACTER THAT WE CELEBRATE
TONIGHT. IT'S THE VITALITY OF
OUR DEMOCRACY, IT'S THE GAINS OF
OUR LONG JOURNEY TO FREEDOM
WERE ASSURED, NONE OF US WOULD
EVER HAVE TO BE COURAGEOUS. NONE
OF US WOULD EVER HAVE TO RISK
ANYTHING TO PROTECT US. BUT IT'S
IN... ITS VERY PRECARIOUSNESS
THAT COURAGE BECOMES POSSIBLE
AND ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. JOHN
F. KENNEDY KNEW THAT OUR BEST
HOPE AND OUR MOST POWERFUL
ANSWER TO OUR DOUBTS AND TO OUR
FEARS LIES INSIDE EACH OF US, IN
OUR WILLINGNESS TO JOYFULLY
EMBRACE OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS
CITIZENS, TO STAY TRUE TO OUR
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR HIGHEST AND
BEST IDEALS. TO MAINTAIN OUR
REGARD AND CONCERN FOR THE POOR
AND THE AGED AND THE
MARGINALIZED, TO PUTS OUR
PERSONAL AND PARTY INTERESTS
ASIDE WHEN DUTY TO OUR COUNTRY
CALLS OR WHEN CONSCIENCE DEMAND
S. THAT'S THE SPIRIT THAT HAS
BROUGHT AMERICA SO FAR AND
THAT'S THE SPIRIT THAT WILL
ALWAYS CARRY US TO BETTER DAYS.
AND I TAKE THIS HONOR THAT YOU
HAVE BESTOWED ON ME HERE TONIGHT
AS A REMINDER THAT EVEN OUT OF
OFFICE I MUST DO ALL THAT I CAN
TO ADVANCE THE SPIRIT OF SERVICE
THAT J.F.K. REPRESENTS. THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH. MAY GOD BLESS
YOU AND MAY HE BLESS THESE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. THANK
YOU. [APPLAUSE] DO I TAKE IT
WITH ME? DO I PACK IT UP?
[APPLAUSE]
PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR THOSE
COMMENTS. I THANK THE
AMBASSADOR, CAROLINE KENNEDY,
FOR HER EFFORTS IN HELPING US
PREPARE AND IMPLEMENT THIS GREAT
EVENING TODAY. AND I
PARTICULARLY THANK JEFF IMMULT
AND GENERAL ELECTRIC FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP FOR PROVIDING THIS
THIS EVENING. [APPLAUSE] LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, I ASK YOU PLEASE,
PLEASE, STAY IN THE TENT UNTIL
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS MOTORCADE,
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN, UNTIL THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS MOTORCADE
HAVE DEPARTED AT THE REQUEST OF
THE SECRET SERVICE. THEN THANK
YOU AND A MEMORABLE EVENING. I
THANK YOU ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
LIBRARY AND THE FOUNDATION. HAVE
A GOOD EVENING. BUT PLEASE WAIT
UNTIL THE PRESIDENT DEPARTS
WITH HIS MOTORCADE.